Thank You spider-man I'm so good
hey sorry I'm late happy nice thank you
you too thank you
new dress yes it is hot you know what
just happened
[ __ ] pass pretty beautiful fur here to
pick up a passport please
Mini two spaces pack your suit I just
want to go on my trip with my friends
Europe doesn't really need a friendly
neighborhood spy
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no that's not a nice thing this
you you look pretty too I just play some
time with him de doodle-do my first time
alone I have just finished my own coffee
so nice to finally meet you
in spite of man
your Nick Fury put some clothes on let's
go for a ride is she gonna be okay like
that might want to turn him over so he
doesn't swallow his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker fee but have a job to
do
are you going to step up or not
all along your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad hey everybody its charlie
they finally released the spider-man far
from home trailer so we got to break it
down there were a couple big Easter eggs
we finally actually got some real Uncle
Ben in a spider-man movie even though
they kind of referenced him during his
speech in Captain America Civil War so
we've had Uncle Ben before but we'd
never actually seen any real Uncle Ben's
stuff happening on-screen we'll do an
uber out of that IMAX ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
first big thing is spider-man addressing
a big crowd of people in the stark tech
suit we don't know when this is
happening during the movie but it seems
like it's relatively early after the
events of everybody coming back in
Avengers 4 Amy Pascal herself said the
Spider Man far from home picks up
minutes after the end of the events of
Avengers endgame so this might not
necessarily be that scene this might be
something after like a brief time jump
or something like that she didn't say
anything about not having time jumps so
we don't know exactly how long this
moment is after the end of Avengers 4 we
just know that the beginning of the
movie picks up a little bit after that
but there's nothing in the trailer to
let you know who's still alive and who's
dead like we see no Iron Man Tony Stark
even though we see a whole lot of happy
who seems totally normal and is totally
flirting with Aunt May just like Iron
Man was during Captain America Civil War
and he gets the same reaction from
Spider Man like hey wait a minute what's
what's going on here this is not cool
the Easter Egg on the charity check that
Happy's holding that giant check
synchrony bank is that synchrony bank in
real life released a MasterCard themed
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
there's actual MasterCard that you can
buy with all the Marvel characters on it
but the big thing here is that Aunt May
totally knows that he's spider-man so
he's still in the old stark tech suit he
hasn't got the new one yet we do see
both of the new suits later in the
trailer though but then they start the
Ramones soundtrack I want to be sedated
it's like The Ramones soundtrack that
they use for the credit sequence and
spider-man homecoming with him just
getting ready for his trip mr. del Mar
is back in his new shop they're
rebuilding over the Avengers Tower in
New York City we don't know what's there
but there is a shot of Nick Fury later
with Windows that look
little bit like this so we might be
standing inside this building it could
be shield that's actually buying this
but this could be a different building
somewhere else in a different part of
the world that he's also standing in
they're very careful to show Nick Fury
just looking at the window they don't
pan around to show you what the city
looks like and the background here
doesn't look totally like New York City
so this could totally be in a different
part of the world but I do think we'll
finally find out who actually bought the
Avengers tower at the end of spider-man
homecoming he goes to get his new
passport if you notice the date on it
it's August August is the month of his
first appearance in the comics an
amazing fantasy number 15 although the
actual like day is just a little bit
different he says he doesn't want to be
a friendly neighborhood spider-man in
Europe he just wants to go on vacation
with his friends so he leaves the stark
tech suit behind and he packs his
suitcase which if you notice is the
Easter Egg for Uncle Ben that I talked
about
so BFP is Benjamin Franklin
Parker Uncle Ben was named after
Benjamin Franklin that's why his name is
Benjamin Franklin Parker he gets on the
plane while the Ramones are seeing a
verse about getting on a plane and then
they start jumping around in time so
this isn't totally linear because the
first place you see them is in the
Venice canals you see net leads you see
MJ they have like a brief funny moment
with them staring at each other like a
moment of chemistry they're kind of
teasing a romance subplot between the
two of them getting a little bit
stronger this time he literally calls
her out his MJ because remember she said
at the end of spider-man homecoming my
friends call me MJ the joke was that she
didn't have a whole lot of friends but
now Peter and Ned were her friends I
know everybody thinks that hydro-man is
in the movie there's actually an easter
egg here for amazing spider-man number
212 which i think is an Easter Egg for
hydro-man so this might just be them
trolling if he's not actually in the
movie if this water elemental turns out
to be a different character there's a
joke about them at a performance in
Europe it seems kind of like a Spider
Man three Tobey Maguire Easter Egg like
what he was actually trying to go see MJ
seeing at a concert they have another
funny moment together then Peters
talking about trying to get closer to MJ
and Ned starts joking about the first
time he fell in love it actually seems
like he's with Betty Brant based on some
of these trailer shots like you see him
holding hands when they're running from
this big bridge fight then later you see
Betty put her hand on nedley's shoulder
so maybe they're a couple but then you
have the funny record
scratch moment where the Ramones
soundtrack stops in its knit fury Peter
Parker so happy to meet you and it's a
very funny light reference to Pulp
Fiction like he's just sitting there
watching him and Peter's at his mercy as
if he's gonna do something dangerous but
Nick Fury obviously is trying to get his
help in dealing with these elemental
creatures so this is his big call to
action then you get a bunch of Nick Fury
voiceover during the trailer talking
about him stepping up his game because
remember during infinity war he was
bragging about being an Avenger so this
movie is a little bit more of his
transition from being spider boy as in
like a little high school kid to
becoming spider-man like fully
actualized spider-man the interesting
thing here though is that you see him in
the canals with Nick Fury in the boat
and he's wearing the original stark tech
suit so he hasn't got the new one yet
then they cut to a different shot of
spider-man using his web wings in the
brand-new red black upgraded stark tech
suit to fly into battle or glide into
battle against one of those large fire
elementals now Nick Fury doesn't call
them out by name or anything you just
see him drum spider-man into service
like we need you to step up kid you
gotta help take some of these down but
then in a separate shot elsewhere you
see Maria Hill and Nick Fury trying to
fight one of the sand looking elementals
now remember that because there are
elementals from the Marvel Comics
history their Doctor Strange characters
they're like d-list characters but I
think part of the idea here is that this
is a play by Mysterio involving some of
his illusion technology so I'll talk
about that in a second when we get to
the Mysterio part of the trailer you get
a much better look at that fire
elemental then you get the voiceover
from happy separately in the stark tech
Jack talking about him being all alone
what are you gonna do if your friends
need help how are you gonna handle
things this is probably part of a
separate speech like a funny moment with
happy with him trying to scare
spider-man a little bit like how you're
gonna handle yourself not gonna have the
other Avengers there helping you out I'm
not gonna be there helping you out
there's a separate shot of a bunch of
European thugs busting into a restaurant
with guns this might be unrelated to the
fight against the elementals or any the
Mysterio stuff just some thugs for him
to take down when he does not have his
spider-man suit so he has to get really
creative with the way he takes them down
that doesn't totally give away that he's
actually spider-man then you see Peter
in Prague Czech Republic at the carnival
in a separate fight with his
stealth suit on that Nick Fury gives him
so this is the other second suit that he
gets this also might be an Easter Egg
for the spider-man Mysterio carnival
fight in the comics but the thing about
that was is that in the comics Mysterio
on television taunts spider-man trying
to goad him into a fight in Aunt May is
the one that's watching it so obviously
here it's all them watching Mysterio on
the TV so just remember that even though
they're trying to tell you that the
elementals are the villains of this
movie I think that Mysterio is the real
villain and he's behind the elementals
and he's just creating them with his
special illusion suit technology that we
get a shot of him getting ready to fight
the water elemental and the Venice
canals we saw the behind the scenes that
Tom Holland posted of this a little
while ago because he doesn't have his
spider-man suit like he's getting ready
to fight the water elemental and he
doesn't have any of his gear and it
looks like while he's trying to figure
out what he's going to do Mysterio
appears seemingly out of thin air in a
puff of green smoke just like he does in
the comics and says you don't want any
part of this is if it's sort of his
superhero line then blast it with green
looking energy that looks just like the
Green Smoke that he puffed out up as if
he's channeling magic the same way that
Doctor Strange would channel magic it's
just a slightly different texture in
color but obviously you know Mysterio is
not a real magician he's more of a
technologist like Tony Stark so we got
to dig into this in a second but you see
him fly into battle in his tech suit
with full-blown
comic-book fishbowl and you see like
this giant symbol appear while he's
flying in or trying to fight this water
elemental the other big comic book
Easter egg in here is for Mysterio's
first like real big appearance in the
comics where he tried to go to the Daily
Bugle and make himself look like a hero
to take down evil spider-man because
he'd been masquerading making it look
like spider-man had been committing
crimes all over town so Mysterio tried
to make himself look like a hero during
this is just an easter egg for that big
first comic book appearance then you get
the sort of post-credit scene with Ned
Leeds sitting in a chair with the other
members of their trip watching Mysterio
fight the monster in a battle but as a
nice reminder that Ned Leeds is the man
in the chair although they did say that
he gets more to do in this movie than he
did in the last one so even though he's
still the man in the chair he gets to do
a lot of action stuff but he get the
funny moment with everybody talking
about Mr
as if he's a hero and Flash Thompson
defending him this Asian actor here is a
brand-new character we don't know who
he's playing but it is probably going to
be a comic book character because even
though they don't have their comic book
personas pretty much all of Peters
classmates are notable characters from
the comics but he has the funny moment
where he says he's like Thorne iron man
rolled into one
then Flash Thompson defends spider-man
what he has a totally dope suit and he
defends the neighborhood hey what's up
dick wat as Peter walks up and gives
them the big thumbs up over the most
part this is like a longer version of
the Brazil Comic Con trailer that they
showed and then did not drop online like
everybody was like where's the trailer
this is pretty much what they showed off
at that comic book convention we got to
talk about Avengers endgame timeline and
what's really going on or probably going
on with Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio
because they've been hyping up about how
he's supposed to be a hero in this movie
but the whole thing is is that he is a
very notable comic book villain and a
member of the sinister six in the comics
but all that Jake Gyllenhaal is said
about the character in real life is that
he's the only person that really
understands how to fight these
elementals which i think is a clue that
the elementals are either other members
of the sinister six that are helping him
out or just complicated illusions that
he uses his special suit tech to control
like he's one of the few people that can
control them because he's literally
controlling them using the technology
that he has built into his suit for the
most part his suit looks like it's based
on shatori tech I think there's just a
continuation of the idea during
spider-man homecoming that you have all
this alien tech that's left over on the
black market and he's pieced it together
that way but I think part of the idea is
spider-man playing a little bit of a
detective sort of putting the pieces
together and unfolding what the reality
is behind these elementals and the other
rumored sinister six characters that are
in the movie because there are supposed
to be other notable comic book villains
we know it seems like shield is a really
big deal so whatever happens during
avengers endgame they come back but for
those are you wondering when we're gonna
get more Avengers endgame footage that
might be at the Super Bowl they also
dropped another different spider-man far
from home trailer with all different
footage so I'll do a separate video for
that tomorrow too but let me know in the
comments what you think about the new
spider-man suits the stealth suit that
looks kind of like the Spider Man in
large suit in the very
Regional Steve Ditko looking black and
red suit what'll happen is is there
supposed to be more trailers dropping
later this week I think there's a Shazam
trailer coming up but leave all your
Marvel video requests in the comments
below click here to rewatch my Avengers
endgame trailer video and click here for
that brand-new Game of Thrones season 8
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody to stay awesome I'll see you
guys tonight